let's consider examples of our principle
that the external torque about a point
as causes the angular momentum of a
system to change about s we've examined
central force problems in which we chose
the point s to be the central point in
which there was no torque now as
examples let's look at a case where we
have a pivoted object so I could take an
example of a object let's see this will
be an overhead view of a ring of radius
R and I'm going to have a mass coming in
I'll call this ring mass M 1 this object
and to this object is coming in with an
initial velocity and this is my pivot
point now when the object m2 is hitting
the ring we have a force f2 on one this
is the collision here's our pivot point
and when this hits the ring we'll have
some type of pivot force I'm just going
to denote the pivot force we're not
quite sure what it will point out but
I'll just say F pivot for the moment is
holding this point in place at the same
time the object will have a force f1 -
acting on the object here's our pivot
point P and now what point should we if
we should we choose to see if there's no
torque about suppose we choose
the pivot point well Pete well clearly
the pivot force has no torque about the
pivot because the vector from the pivot
point to where the pivot force is acting
is zero
remember pivot forces have no torque
about the pivot point however this
collision force will produce a torque
about the pivot and that's the angular
momentum of the Ring is not constant
because the ring will start to rotate
similarly this object is reversing to
will reverse directions or will do
something due to the collision and again
this force will produce a torque that's
equal and opposite to the torque on the
ring this is the torque on the particle
but if we make our system equal to the
particle and the ring so we'll call this
our system is now both the particle and
the ring then these torques are internal
and because they're equal and opposite
forces the RS vector is exactly the same
RS vector the internal torques cancel in
pairs the pivot force produces no torque
so the torque on the system about the
pivot is zero and that tells us that the
angular momentum of the system about
that pivot point initially will be equal
to the angular momentum about that pivot
point finally if we take two initial and
final States in particular suppose our
initial state is here's the pivot our
object is coming in that was M to be I
the moment arm is our and our vector
from here to the object RS initial has a
moment component that way if we put
these vectors tail the tail and figure
out that the angular momentum is
pointing in this direction L initial I
and the moment arm is R then the initial
angular momentum about this pivot point
is just due to this moving object so
that's M to the I and the moment arm is
R and we'll denote its direction that
way now the final angular Mountain let's
imagine that it sticks so we have M 2
pivot and now our ring is going to be
rotating with some Omega final because
this object hits it and notice that this
object is a distance root 2 R from the
pivot point so the final angular
momentum can be two different pieces you
can think of this as a system where we
have I of the system about P times Omega
final because now it's just a rigid body
and the angular momentum of the system
is consisting of two pieces its the
angular momentum of the ring about the
pivot plus the angular momentum of the
particle
about the pivot times Omega final now
this is a center of mass this is the
pivot point P the angular momentum of
the Ring is the angular momentum about
the center we'll use the parallel axis
theorem angular momentum about the
center of mass plus the distance from
the center of mass to the parallel axis
which is a distance R so the first piece
is ICM ring plus M R squared and the
angular mentioned about the particle
this is going in a circle of radius R 2
root 2 R so when we square that by the
way this was mass of the ring was one
mass of the particle was m2 times R
squared which is this distance squared
which is 2 R squared times will make a
final the moment of inertia of the ring
is M 1 R squared about the center of
mass we have a factor 2 we have another
factor of 2 and so we get M 1 plus M 2
times a factor 2 R squared Omega final
which we can call Omega F pointing out
of the board and so now we have a
angular momentum condition which is that
M 2 VI R equals to M 1 plus M 2 R
squared will make a final and that is a
statement that the initial angular
momentum of our system the ring is at
rest here is equal to the final angular
momentum of the system where M 2 is
stuck to the ring and they're all
rotating about this pivot point with
omega final that's the angular momentum
of the system about P will make a final
this is the initial angular momentum and
so I can conclude that Omega final is M
2 VI over 2 m 1 plus M 2 times R
you